Russian President Vladimir Putin is now
officially a wanted man in more than 120
countries on Friday the international
criminal court issued an arrest warrant
for Putin for war crimes the court
claims Putin is behind forces abducting
and deporting thousands of Ukrainian
children to Russia and
russian-controlled land since the War
Began more than a year ago a Kremlin
spokesman called the arrest warrant
outrageous and unacceptable Raymond
incensio has more
good morning the international criminal
court is now backing Ukraine's claim
that Russia is abducting its Children
ukrainians Here feel this is the first
step to Justice
Russian propaganda claims the country is
trying to save Ukraine's children and
that the hearts of Russians are big and
benevolent
but the international criminal court
today was clear Russia is kidnapping and
re-educating children as Russians
accused of war crimes our President
Vladimir Putin himself and Maria lavova
bilova the director of these alleged
abductions
it would be impossible to commit such a
criminal operation says president
zlinski without the order of the top
leader of the terrorist State Moscow has
denied the accusations and does not
recognize the ICC the news comes as
diplomatic support arrives from China
today Beijing confirmed president Xi
Jinping will travel to Russia to meet
with Putin on Monday their first summit
since the War Began Beijing has proposed
a ceasefire which the White House
dismissed
and a new show of solidarity for Ukraine
from Slovakia following Poland together
a pledge for at least 17 soviet-designed
fighter jets while old or in need of
repair the hope is it could break
Europe's hesitation to send even more
warplanes
and Putin will not be arrested as long
as he stays inside Russia but if he
travels to any ICC member country 123 of
them that warrant means that he could be
arrested it's worth it to note the U.S
does not recognize the ICC for CBS
Saturday morning Raymond innocencio
Odessa Ukraine